[Musica]
salmi youtubers allora prima di iniziare
la recensione vorrei dirvi due così non
vorrei ringraziarvi ma sempre
ringraziare stai tu mamma mia oh
ma così che vuoi tu cosa vuoi perché
troppo tempo a ringraziare ma fregatene
su non so che ringrazio spesso lasciami
finire che questa cosa importante
prima di tutto grazie mille per il 50
mila iscritti perché sono siete
tantissimi spropositati non so neanche
più come si scriveva numeri 50mila
grazie mille veramente immensi
altra cosa importante per me è successa
una piccola cosa
domenico marotta è riuscito a scrivere
un articolo e farlo pubblicare sulla
rivista best movie di maggio infatti se
voi andate a pagina e la rivista lista
da volava recessione e la recensione
sensore sì sì ma mi lasci finire aspetta
se voi andate a pagina 47 di bass movie
di maggio il mio faccione in un articolo
veramente scritto molto bene quindi
grazie mille domenico marocco ma a
bratto sono io
eh sì che ci sei anche tu ma se non mi
lasci finire
comunque io vi ringrazio perché io
ringrazio domenico marotta per essere
riuscito a fare scrivere un articolo su
di noi sulla rivista best movie è però
io ringrazio soprattutto voi che mi
avete c'è e grazie a voi alla fine se si
sono arrivato qui è qualcosa di
veramente fantastico io non ho parole
per ringraziarvi grazie
non ci può essere un'altra parola che
non sia grazie perché l'ho usata
veramente troppe volte inizio a venire
veramente la nausea quando dico grazie
ma è l'unica parola purtroppo per
ringraziarvi io sono veramente col cuore
in mano
non so veramente cosa dirvi spero che
victor sia riuscito a comprare il
vesuvio in tempo
grazie mille e diamo il via al terzo
film della trilogia della risata
[Musica]
il terzo ed ultimo punto
o film della trilogia della risata e
violet c3 vi dico subito che questa non
sarà una recensione normale perché weil
c3 è il mio primo film brutto non
intenzionale che abbia mai visto
non intenzionale nel senso che l'avevo
letto in alcune recensioni questo film
ma io non ero ancora in cerca di film
brutti ce ne avevo visti tanti ma non
sono mai andato cercarmi quelli che
avevo visto nero visti in tv questo
invece è stato il primo film che mi sono
andato a cercare e che non mi sono
pentito di aver visto circa dice ma non
sarà una recensione normale perché non
metterò i cinque punti e non mettere i
cinque punti perché non ci sono cinque
punti da mettere praticamente ci
potrebbe benissimo essere un solo punto
che ho scritto tutto il cacchio di film
bailen sheet 3 come dice il titolo è il
terzo film di anche se una trilogia
composta da vari cit un ovaio in c2
in breve la trama è una mezza recensione
dei primi due film la saga va in uscita
diretta da un ragazzo ha chiamato
andreas china's che si diverte con
pochissimo budget veramente pochissimo a
fare degli splatter il primo va il cit è
un'oscenità veramente un'oscenità sia
come effetti speciali sia come regia si
è come recitazione è praticamente
amatoriale veramente a livello
amatoriale o qualcosa veramente fatto in
casa la cosa più brutta di tutto film
comunque la riggi e le inquadrature sono
tutte a mano tutte fuori fuoco e con
ogni mezzo metteva cerchi certe
inquadrature del tipo in notturna che si
vedeva solo una sfera in mezzo allo allo
schermo tutta verdognola grigia uno
schifo la trama parla di carl un uomo
che fa una strage di tutte le persone
che incontra fine la trama del secondo
me il cit che questa volta è un po
meglio il girato ma proprio un pizzico
nel senso che non ti vien voglia di
fermarlo dopo dieci secondi ma dopo due
minuti
la trama è praticamente la stessa però
con il figlio di carli film di cannes
nasce e sotto i consigli della madre
mezza psicopatica ammazza tutti quelli
che vede fine devo dire che i primi due
film io detestati veramente veramente
detestati perché sono atroci da guardare
non nel senso della violenza perché c'è
molta violenza e questi film c'è la
violenza è veramente diciamo gratuita
però sono tanti film con violenza
gratuita quindi non sto qua a giudicare
però è orribile sotto ogni punto di
vista c'è da guardare e veramente un
pugno a tutti e due gli occhi il terzo
film invece no quando sono andato a
cercarlo e a trovarlo sono rimasto
stupito senso cerchio positivo infatti e
dopo aver visto vhils i tre che ho
iniziato a amare i film trash veramente
amarli c e apprezzarli per quello che
sono e iniziare a fare recensioni non
video ai tempi con molte persone avevo
msn msn aveva il blog live e l'icif i
caveau di tutto tra cui recensioni
scritte di film poi sono passato a
youtube
quindi se vi dovete ringraziare qualcuno
per le mie recensioni e ringraziate
andreassi nas bastardo
partiamo dalla trama di vaio in citt 3
dalla trama non ne ho idea
praticamente il figlio di carlo del
secondo film apre un accampamento di i
suoi seguaci tutti quelli con la
maschera di metallo che ammazza chiunque
passi da quelle parti possa aver caso
tre persone a caso che arrivano da una
barca
uno di questi scappa incontra due
ragazzi asiatici che a furia di arti
marziali e spade e riescono ad ammazzare
tutti quanti si è un pochino più
complicata dei primi due film ma
comunque non è un cacchio di senso di
esistere
uno degli aspetti che ritorna
maggiormente nei film di cina se la
violenza
aspettate per dare per l'enfasi magari
metto una scritta una delle cose che
ricorre di più nei film di andreas cina
se la violenza e senza e
ma l'ho data più enfasi mettendo la
scritta c'è un ammontare di violenza
nelle sue pellicole che è spaventoso e
devo dire che molti dei suoi effetti
sono anche fatti bene visto alcuni sono
fatti benissimo ho detto alcuni ma
ovviamente non avrei messo il film della
trilogia della risata se non facesse
sbellicare dal ridere
e credetemi che il film faccia
sbellicare è un eufemismo
pensate soltanto che il dottore in
questo campo qui e nazista con tanto di
baffetti e capelli pettinati da un lato
è ovvio come un regista che si chiama
andrea schina ass
non potevo aspettarmi altrimenti da una
battuta adesso non stiamo qui a sky
senza dimenticarci però che la regia è
comunque orrenda
se guardate a volte mette di filtri dove
il bianco aumenta a dismisura tanto che
a volte non si riesce a vedere
assolutamente nulla
e in questi filtri framerate del film i
frame per secondo cambiano passano da da
60 credo c'è da qui dei filmini fatti in
casa a quelli fatti a firma 27 29
perché perche nas la violenza non è solo
nel film ma deve arrivare anche fuori
quindi lui vuole farvi sanguinare gli
occhi lui vi osserva e voi immaginate di
tutto quello che vi sto facendo vedere
adesso per uno che non aveva mai visto
un film è effettivamente somma inizio
good è già tanto che non mi sia di
svegliato in ospedale
riprendiamo con il film ad un certo
punto inizia un flashback in questo
flashback si vede card junior cioè il
figlio di quelli del del primo film che
sevizia due donne ovviamente non ve lo
faccio vedere perché se non mi cacciano
proprio dall'italia ma vi dico vi faccio
vedere soltanto con cosa card giulio e
servizi alle donne
vi ricordate la scorsa recensione e
attack of the beast critche urss come
l'hanno fatta le creaturine a tenetevi
forte mi tengo forte anch'io via
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ok no questo non può essere spacciato
per una creatura originale ma neanche se
mi ci ficco la mano dentro alla animi tu
non si ferma e un pupazzo basta prossimo
no non me la bevo non me la bevo come se
non bastasse alla violenza degli addetti
di kart junior della foresta arrivano
degli zombie e particola dei tantissimi
combattimenti del film uno peggio
dell'altro
è così
[Musica]
a
c'è però da dire che andrea sua fantasia
in queste cose
pochi soldi ma tanta fantasia e poi ad
un certo punto arriva alla parte che
preferisco e ligia
è ovvio perché gli assassini con il
machete gli zombie in un somma di sugut
non bastano mai
ha tra l'altro complimenti per la
mimetica nera in pieno giorno in una
foresta completamente verde
i combattimenti e gli effetti speciali
si sprecano
però ci sono due cose che mi fanno
impazzire di questo combattimento
il finale
[Musica]
prima di finire questa detenzione sicuro
fa poi un infarto e non ho idea di come
chiamarla questa scena
guardate bella e gustatevela il più
possibile
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e dovrei anche commentarla ve la faccio
rivedere uno dei ninja vola verso uno
dei sopravvissuti è questo qui che in
tenendo la spada fermissima non sai che
in 2 manco fosse una motosega taranto
usando un montaggio che riuscita a
rendere la scena alla perfezione è un
genio
e poi ovviamente arriva il gran finale
il combattimento che tutti stavano
aspettando
ed è anche qui un tripudio di sangue
violenza decapitazioni che si vede
benissimo che sta nascondendo la testa
sotto e il tutto finisce come una
tamarrata il mare è sopravvissuto con un
pugno book al petto del nemico con alta
ma non lancia una grata balla lancia
altissima giusto soltanto per poi
prenderla al volo con la mano con cui ha
bucato il petto poi come se bastasse
gliela ficca in bocca scappa e bomba
esplode tutto
[Musica]
neanche i quali i runners abbia potuto
recare andrè hashish nas per immaginarsi
queste cose quindi questo era vaillant
ship e mi rimarrà per sempre nel cuore
come puoi non iniziare a fare le
recensioni di film brutti dopo aver
visto questo film
e come al solito io sono senza parole
ragazzi grazie mille grazie per tutti i
commenti tutti i complimenti tutti i
messaggi tutte le magliette che mi
comprate
grazie mille per tutto quanto mi avete
dato tantissimo sotto questo punto di
vista e vi ringrazio tantissimo
detto questo purtroppo la trilogia della
risata è finito
riprenderò a fare recensioni normali
purtroppo ho visto che in mia assenza
l'asylum ha sfornato nuovi film
[Musica]